now to mississippi and the worsening
crisis over a lack of drinking water
long lines formed in jackson for bottled
water instead but now the government is
running out of that as well
all this because of damage to a
treatment plant due to flooding janet
chameleon is in jackson for the very
latest janet good morning to you
jerica good morning the water crisis
here is impacting just about every
aspect of life and for parents this is a
big one the kids are home indefinitely
as jackson public schools have gone to
remote learning because there's no
running water in the classrooms and
while the state says it will fix the
water treatment plant here this morning
there is no word on when jackson's water
will be safe to drink
a small airstrip in jackson is now a
water distribution site how long have
you been in line here
about two and a half hours it's one of
the only ways for residents like brianna
barber to get clean drinking water we've
been boiling water for about a month now
and right now we've just been waiting in
line to get some
free water because all the stores are
out
much of jackson has been under a boil
water notice since july after the health
department found cloudy water in the
system
then over the weekend major flooding
forced the shutdown of the water
treatment plant leaving more than 150
thousand people without clean water no
showers no brushing teeth no drinking
from the tap
they are moving cars through here
quickly it's just one case per car they
say they have enough for 600 cars but by
the looks of the line it runs for
several miles
mississippi's drinking water
infrastructure system is one of the
worst in the nation earning a degrade in
2020 from the american society of civil
engineers
a winter storm in february of last year
left thousands in jackson without
running water after pipes froze
a public safety commission report found
challenges in jackson including frozen
equipment loss of power and outdated
water infrastructure the residents of
jackson
are worthy
they are worthy of a dependable system
jackson mayor chokwe antar lumumba says
the city has spent every dollar it can
to fix staffing shortages and
maintenance issues with its water
treatment plants but needs help from the
state
this is a set of accumulated problems
based on deferred maintenance that has
not taken place
over decades
some money for the repairs could come
from that recently passed infrastructure
bill and while the state of mississippi
is slated to get 75 million dollars for
water issues here's the catch the cost
of repairs here in jackson alone
could be billions
tony
yeah if you don't do it over time it
really piles up janet for us in jackson
mississippi janet thank you very much